[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Disney Princesses have a lot in common
like the fact that they all had tragic
beginnings and happily ever afters
vanellope von schweetz had it right when
she asked the princesses are you each
Disney Princess had her reasons for
running away from home and we're about
to reveal them so stay tuned there's
nothing like an evil stepmother to
encourage you to pack your bags and move
out but unfortunately for these Disney
princesses leaving wasn't exactly an
option
after Cinderella's father tragically
passed away she was forced to live under
the same roof as her evil stepmother
Lady Tremaine and her two wicked
stepsisters Cinderella went from being a
highborn child to a scullery maid
overnight with her fairy godmothers help
Cinderella ran away from home for a
single night and it changed her entire
life Snow White was also forced to leave
her home due to an evil stepmother if
the Evil Queen had gotten what she
wanted Snow White would no longer be in
the picture so running away with snows
only chance at survival
although Rapunzel's story is very
different than Snow White's and
Cinderella's she also falls under the
umbrella of wicked stepmothers Rapunzel
was kidnapped at birth and raised to
believe that her captor was her mother
she ran away before ever finding out the
truth but soon the pieces of the puzzle
started coming together you could say
that Rapunzel ran away due to having a
controlling mother so by default that
also lumps her into the category of
Disney Princesses who ran away due to
having controlling parents Princess
Jasmine knows a thing or two about
controlling parents after all her dad
the Sultan of Agrabah forbade her from
leaving the palace walls for most of her
life after years of solitude and boredom
Jasmine chose to directly disobey her
dad and hopped over the palace walls in
pursuit of adventure the same can be
said about Princess Merida
whose mother was so controlling she had
to flee to escape an arranged marriage
Merida of dunbroch was so angry with her
mother that a chain of unfortunate
events soon follows but hey they worked
out in the end and the very same thing
happens with Ariel and her daughter
melody despite having a controlling
father for her own princess Ariel went
on to repeat the cycle she forbade her
daughter melody of ever entering the sea
despite it being a huge part of who she
is melody chose to run away from home
and get away from her controlling mother
but in the end it all worked out for the
best
although Ariel knows a thing or two
about having a governing parents the
princess ran away from home for a very
different reason than her daughters
Ariel chose to run away for love which
led her to nearly destroying everything
she held dear she gave up her voice for
a pair of legs but luckily for her love
prevails
[Music]
Princess Anna also ran away for love
however the love in her heart was very
different than aerials on the left
arendelle in the middle of a snowstorm
to bring her sister Elsa back home on
his love for Elsa is what ended up
saving her in the end much like Ariel
Pocahontas is also familiar with the
concept of forbidden love although she
never ran away from home she did sneak
out of her village to meet with John
Smith although the couple didn't end up
together
Pocahontas would later journey to a new
world to help save her people this leads
us to our next reason for running away
from home which seems to be a popular
one among princesses like Mulan Belle
and Moana these three princesses ran
away to play the hero fom Mulan risked
her life to save her father which proved
to be the biggest sacrifice of all she
ran away from home in the dead of night
to pose as her father's Sun King her act
of true heroism saved all of China and
turned her into a princess you have
saved us all much like Mulan Belle's
motive for running away had everything
to do with saving her father Belle
risked her life to find and save her dad
take me instead
whereas Mulan and Belle fled the safety
of their homes to save their fathers
Mawile last month newly to save her
people Moana was chosen to find Maui and
help him return to city's heart Moana
journeyed into the unknown to save the
entire world and she managed to find
herself in the process then there's
Tiana and Aurora who had to flee their
homes in hopes of breaking a curse
Tiana ran away from home after being
turned into a frog by Prince Naveen she
fled her hometown in search of a cure
and soon found herself going down the
Bayou Princess Aurora on the other hand
was forced to flee her castle in hopes
of escaping Maleficent wicked curse she
was raised in the forest by flora fauna
and Merryweather where she would
eventually meet her one true love
Aurora spent most of her life running
away from a curse and last but not least
it's clean Elsa who unlike the other
Disney Princesses has her own special
reason for running away from home Elsa
had no choice but to flee arendelle
after she exposed her powers
[Applause]
Elsa was unable to control her abilities
which put everyone at risk on top of
that she was tired of hiding who she
truly was and simply wanted to be
herself Merida also fell into this
category
but in the end Merida didn't need to run
away to be herself she'd always acted
herself to begin with Elsa on the other
hand never once told anyone about her
powers and forced herself into solitude
so there you have it guys the real
reason each Disney princess ran away
from home although every princess had
their reasons for fleeing they managed
to beat the odds and follow their hearts
in your opinion which Disney Princess
had the best reason for running away let
us know in the comments section below
and that's a wrap don't forget to
subscribe for more videos about your
favorite Disney Princesses and be sure
to give this video a big thumbs up
thanks for watching the things we'll
catch you next time
[Music]